reunimos a 7 james y soy yo si soy en si
soy en si soy en si soy yo si soy yen si
soy en sí
uno es un milenio si el grupo descubre
quién es el mentiroso obtendrán un
premio en efectivo
si el mentiroso sobrevive él ganará el
premio
quién es el impostor
[Música]
mi corazón está latiendo muy rápido
cuál fue su película favorita de la
infancia king kong charlie y la fábrica
de chocolate' sand se dice de mí es de
mis favoritas la miel hershey school
musical' envía bien sigamos school
musical' educan rock camp rock
cualquiera de disney ella parecía mayor
más madura que el resto de nosotros
también estaba haciendo muchas preguntas
así que yo pensé algo está pasando aquí
qué edad tienen tengo 19 yo tengo 21
tengo 22 tengo 18 24 años el 93 tengo 22
soy la más joven aquí si todos usan
tictoc ahora sí bien en cuanto a las
tendencias cuáles fueron sus favoritas o
cualquier cosa de la melodía adoro la
melodía de las canciones de doria cut
your xxi
con la fila estoy tratando de pensar en
uno es que viven muchos vídeos de perros
y no se me ocurre uno ningún gen si
habla de vídeos de perros me parece un
poco sospechoso
ustedes usan facebook sólo para vender
cosas por marcas solo y por la familia
de marley y por los abuelos porque no
entienden
es la luz muy bonita la iluminación
siempre confía en tu instinto parecía
demasiado joven había algo en el
la lista hacía muchas preguntas para
desviar la atención de sí misma
wow me encanta tu suéter gracias tal vez
se sintieron intimidados por mi
confianza y mis preguntas debí haberme
quedado callada en la primera ronda cuál
es tu género musical favorito me gusta
mucho el harén beat y el hip hop
danielys en salud también excelentes me
gusta el hip hop y lo alternativo
escucho más pop aunque no sé mucho de
música sí contra el pop cómodo ya cut
seguras y cuando dijo música country no
creo que sea muy bien sí así que creo
que estaba tratando de fingir
sospechoso todos ustedes trabajan sí de
acuerdo que hacen soy un anfitrión a 21
lo espera estos son reclutó enfermeras
durante la comida reclutamos enfermeras
para trabajar en los hospitales es
genial si matas tic soy profesor de
música
es decir clases particulares de piano o
de violín y de canto éstas se
incrementaron durante el commit porque
direcciones por zoom pasaste por muchas
pruebas en la escuela para eso yo obtuve
mi calificación en una sección privada
sabes cuánto tiempo te llevo fueron unos
seis meses no fue mucho tiempo pero
estudié música en el colegio pues no fue
para gráfica cuatro años cuatro años yo
me gradué en 2019 con 24 años yo siempre
fui el mayor ahí por eso estaba muy
nervioso de que me eliminarán antes de
tiempo ya sabes donde compran ropa
compro en zara urban outfitters
el dinero estoy en contra de la moda
rápida compro en buffalo exchange es una
tienda de segunda mano muy buena es algo
de los ángeles y es realmente genial get
es mi favorito
definitivamente el hermoso tema
ingeniera siempre le tomó algo dios yen
si suelen usar zapatos deportivos
enormes y pantalones holgados por lo
general no suelen usar bermudas
cazadoras ni cosas así o cuál fue su
serie animada favorita o dios mío avatar
la leyenda de rey lear' show jimmy
neutron probablemente y nickelodeon va
ganando los chicos del barrio era lo mío
pero iba a preguntar por no ser
cartoon network y
disney
aunque realmente quisiera ser su amiga
cuando hablo de la escuela de música y
de la industria musical sentí que eso
requería mucha formación
[Música]
me sorprendió pensé que rubiera la que
se daba por muerta parecía genial pero
también una millennial zeta dijiste que
también eres muy de lo verdad cuánto
tiempo llevas haciéndolo desde hace un
año o dos que también es divertido o
tengo una curiosidad los estándares de
belleza han cambiado porque sé que los
jeans si han hecho muy buen trabajo para
romper las barreras como el body
positivo y ti sí y de hecho hace poco
tuvieron una modelo que estaba
embarazada y en traje de baño en miami
fue asombroso y no lo habían hecho antes
me entiendes sí y estoy a favor me gusta
el body positivo ti rubí iba por mí y
pensé dios mío si viene por mí es porque
quiere desviar la atención de sí misma
cuando nacieron no tienen que decir el
año marzo enero estamos en mayo 7 de
marzo el 11 de marzo
me encanta piscis el 25 de septiembre
libra genial soy del 17 de septiembre
así que virgo
no dije el mío todos hablaron de sus
signos soy capricornio alguien quiere
preguntarme
quién es tu estrella pop favorita qué
quieres decir qué quieres decir
ryan está a mi derecha y lo escuché
respirar tan fuerte que creo que este
punto es el más sospechoso
siento que está dando su información
para que nadie sospeche de ella
[Música]
muy bien los veré más tarde diviértanse
por favor levanten la mano si todavía
tienen dudas de haber atrapado al top o
quieren seguir jugando en 3 2 1
bien tengo una pregunta creen que a
otras generaciones no lo sé les cuesta
entender a los yen sí y no lo sé de
todas nuestras creencias creo que lo que
es genial con las quien si es que somos
muy muy diversos las generaciones están
en rangos de 20 años no es verdad pues
creo que ahora los yen si rompemos eso y
nos estamos fusionando todos en una sola
línea colectiva si esto tiene sentido si
esto también siento eso incluso
socialmente por ejemplo durante las
elecciones
con todo lo de trump decían que
reservará los asientos nadie se
presentaba viajero brillante una buena
forma de que los ciencia se hicieran oír
su voz si tenía una pregunta sobre tu
trabajo si te dedicas no ser enfermera
tú reflotó enferme también reclutas si
estupendo es muy rico no te iniciaste a
través de linkedin no sabía qué hacer y
tuve una extraña situación escolar con
la que tuve que lidiar así que cambié mi
camino muy rápidamente y eso sí como
ruby habló mucho sobre cosas adultas y
muy bien
entonces pensé que había una posibilidad
de que ella fuese el topo has hecho algo
grande algo así y estuve en broadway
tu participación y cdl al musical sí
hice de michael sombras el hermano
pequeño ya no tengo nada más lo siento
no sé siento que no puedo relacionarme
con ustedes porque son mayores que yo
unos dos años pero sigue siendo
incómodos
dijo que le gustaba la actuación y yo
pensé que quizás estuviera actuando
ahora mismo
o no
[Risas]
pasó
estaba tan decepcionado pensé que había
hecho un buen trabajo por favor rebaten
la mano si aún tienen dudas de haber
atrapado al topo odia si quieren seguir
jugando
seguí me acuerdo la mayoría no quiere
continuar vamos a terminar el juego
ahora
si las luces son fuertes significa que
eliminaron al topo y ganan si las luces
son rojas el topo sigue aquí y ustedes
pierden
por un momento creí que era haciendo en
la vida estaba en blanco no pensé que
iba a ganar pensé en casa me dijeron que
no ganaría en realidad yo también creía
que no iba a ganar pero aún así el
milenio por favor dé un paso adelante y
revele su identidad en 3 2 1
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no lo sabía ni siquiera me voy a ir
puedo ser honesta vote por ti en la
primera ronda quieres saber por qué por
qué por qué llevas bermudas
jubilee vive intensamente